is converses okay now what we've learnt
about angles and parallel lines right
we've learnt a few patterns right we've
learnt a few patents the important thing
about them is that these patterns you
can reverse them you can turn them
around here's what I mean okay what did
we say before we said corresponding
angles are equal this is just an example
we did this for alternate and continuity
we see of course where the angles are
equal on parallel lines we said that
okay now I can take this statement and I
can reverse it and it's still true let's
say that again
I can take a statement turn around and
it was still true here's what I mean I
can say if corresponding angles are
equal if they are only then then the
lines that they are must me absolutely
without a question must be parallel and
the lines must be parallel so here's
what I mean look at the first one if I
told you these are two parallel lines
okay and then I told you this angle up
the top was 80 degrees
they did say well they're parallel lines
in the corresponding it was equal so
this one must also be 80 but this second
one is different this is called the
converse right of the first state move
when you turn it around like that that's
the name against that means if you take
some lines you don't know whether
they're parallel or not okay but I say
all right this one this one's 75 and
this one also happens to be 75 if
they're equal now I can conclude
they must be parallel you see how I'm
doing it in reverse
okay now here's the important thing
right this is not always true statements
and there converses don't always match
up on giving an example okay I despite
people who may believe otherwise I'm a
normal human being so I was born with
two eyes okay here's me okay
don't we gonna be was born with two eyes
all right but but what would be the
converse of that could I say I was born
with two your eyes therefore I'm a
normal human being will no you can't say
that you can I'd say the comments
because I could be I could be a whole
number of things I could be a fish I
could be a lion I could be a [ __ ] so
please make sure you have this idea of
the converse now and how they remain
together